good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you come out so you can have a positive
impact on yourself on your family your
community and the world so to help you
on your journey today's message is
measure momentum over to you simon Sinek
[Music]
success is an elusive thing right what
is it
and I think it's very interesting that
if most people can't define success well
it means you made X amount of dollars or
but if you make X amount of dollars but
you spend more are you successful or
what means you come home happy every day
ok how do you know when you're happy you
know so I think success is a funny thing
which is we all seem to pursue it but we
don't know how to measure it or actually
how to define it so how do you pursue
something that you can't measure
fascinating so when people say to me how
do you measure success the question we
all have to ask ourselves am i
successful I don't know I mean I had a
good year last year and what does that
mean does that mean I made a lot of
money doesn't mean is really happy oh
I'll let you decide right maybe neither
maybe both I had a good year last year
but am i successful and the answer is no
I don't feel I am because I'm trying to
build a world that doesn't exist yet I'm
trying to build a world in which 90% of
people go home at the end of the day
feeling fulfilled by the work that they
do so I definitely took a step a big
step forward towards that goal but I'm
still so far away so somebody said to me
then how do you know if you're
successful and the answer is if it can
go by itself and so what is more
interesting to me as a measurement of
success is not the the the markers per
se it's not the the financial goal or
the the size of the house that you want
to buy those are nice things go for it
those are but those are not measurements
of success those are just nice things to
collect along the way for me its
momentum
I want to measure momentum which is you
know when when something is moving and
you start to see a lose
Oh give it a push because if you don't
get it pushed it's gonna stop and an
object in stasis it's much harder to get
going it requires a lot more energy to
get something started than it does to
keep it going right and so if you don't
let it stop and you can keep it going
it's this you know it still might slow
down down there but you can get it going
again much easier and for me the
opportunity is to get the ball rolling
faster and faster and faster and faster
and faster and bigger and bigger and
bigger and Slyke it's Noble and my
responsibility is because it's not
rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet I need to still keep it
going to find that critical mass where
it can go and at the point it can go by
itself without me then I will find
something else to do and that may not
happen in my lifetime I think we must
all stop measuring promotions salaries
and these things but rather measure the
momentum of your career does my career
have momentum can I see it moving in the
right direction can I see it gathering
Moss you know can I see that it's easy
becoming easier for me to keep the
momentum it's becoming easier for me to
grow the size of this thing it's it's
requiring less effort that's the thing
we need to measure that's the thing that
we need to be cognizant of which is the
momentum of our career is not just the
the markers that we think define our
success there's a famous saying in
business that what gets measured gets
managed in other words what you are
measuring is what you're going to work
on if you have a specific goal that
you're working towards every day then
that's what you're gonna work towards
every day right once you start tracking
something that's where you're gonna
guide your effort and so it's really
important that you track things that are
meaningful and important to you for me
money has never been the primary target
money for me is always a byproduct of
having an impact the more value you're
giving the more impactful what you're
creating is the more money you're going
to make and so I would much rather track
those efforts instead of the byproduct
which is gonna be money so I couldn't
tell you how much money I have in my
bank account right now or how many
investments I have or for trying to
dance salsa what our top line and bottom
line is right now I couldn't tell you
it's important like money's still
important it's not like forget about
money doesn't mean anything you know I
have access to the data and I make
decisions based off of it but it's never
the number one thing it's not the most
important metric right as soon as you
start making decisions only based on
money you're gonna lose the most
successful entrepreneurs and the
look at who they are look at your heroes
they profiled tons of them on this
channel the most important metrics they
track is never money and so then you've
got to find what is the thing that means
the most to you
so it was an example on YouTube I track
my subscribers the subscriber number in
general is not a huge deal it's not like
I hit a million subscribers and now I'm
worthy or I hit five millions of
skywards at 10 million subscribers and
now I'm worthy right and I'm not gonna
do anything just to hit that number
because I could do a lot of things I
could create a lot of negative content
and entrepreneurs fighting each other
that could lead to a lot more views and
a lot more subscribers it doesn't fill
me up for me when somebody chooses to
subscribe to my channel it means that
they like my content it means that I'm
having an impact
so it's loving the work it's loving the
day-to-day and having a meaningful
metric that you can use to measure is
your momentum growing are you succeeding
are you having some results so on the
YouTube side it's the big subscriber
number and it's also the day-to-day it's
the comments it's a qualitative right
seeing you guys comment every day seeing
the impact that it's having having
somebody say this video changed my life
totally improve my perspective have a
big impact like that those little things
a day to day the little why's right like
say Big Y little Y those little Y's keep
me motivated as well as that big Y
chasing down the big number the billion
entrepreneurs I'm million subscribers
the next goal of 10 million subscribers
if you look at TBS the main metric that
we measure is student satisfaction so
after a student has finished a class we
send out a survey how did you like this
instructor how is the experience at TDS
and it's on the scale out of 5 and my
goal is for every instructor at the
school to beat my all-time high so I
have the all-time high historical record
of being the best instructor at Toronto
that's also it's like a four point nine
to something I want every instructor to
beat me not as a legal thing like I just
want them to perform really well my goal
is to make them better than I was when I
was teaching that means we're having a
huge impact on the students who are
coming in right if my instructors are
scoring a four point nine five out of
five on average that's a pretty big
result that's a lot of satisfaction that
are going through our customers and our
students and so that's the main metric
that we track every single quarter and
my goal is to help
become better than I was and give a way
better result for our customers and so
I'd highly encourage you to think about
what is the metric that really means
something how do you measure momentum in
your business yes money is important
it's not everything and it's not nothing
it's still important but it's not number
one it's number two or three it's a
little bit further down that list but
it's still close to the top what's at
the top though like how do you measure
your success how do you measure that
you're making the right decisions how do
you measure the momentum in your
business I would love to hear from you
please leave that metric down in
comments below I think I could really
inspire some of the people watching and
I might learn something new as well so
share your thoughts I also want to give
a quick shout out to a deal Zhu Barry
from superpower solutions calm thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word I really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoyed the video
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
folks the difference in the great
coaches and the average and ordinary
coaches is the ability to get momentum
and to keep momentum think about this
folks
äô williams for 20 consecutive years
grew now during those 20 consecutive
years we changed companies five times I
had to terminate the number one producer
in our company on two different
occasions and it was almost impossible
to get terminated
you know from ayo Williams we had Wars
with the regulator's we were kicked out
of Mississippi for two weeks
Canada pass through where there was no
part-time recruits Texas limited the
number of recruits we could 350 a year
and with all of that al Williams grew
for 20 straight years now how do you
grow this is the difference in a pro a
real pro and an average and ordinary
coach there are three things you do now
to guarantee you keep momentum when you
get it going
number one you grow by multiplication
you grow by multiplication you've got to
always be promoting people the district
leader to division leader to our VP okay
because once you get things growing by
multiplication then what you have or you
have hundreds then hundreds or thousands
of people that are doing what you are
trying to do okay building friends
praise and recognizing people recruiting
best friends does that make sense and
see once you have once you're growing my
multiplication that's the greatest
opportunity for you to keep that
momentum that you've kept okay that
makes sense all right number two the
second thing
I mean keeping this momentum once you
have it is you've got to have an enemy
you've got to have some kind of
injustice out there you're trying to
create you know you've got to have an
edge I don't care if you in the in the
real estate business right if somebody's
charging a charging a let's say a 10%
commission on just raw land that you
sell out there then you do it for eight
and a half percent or something right
you've got to have an edge over the
enemy you've got to have an enemy you're
trying to beat out there right now we
were fortunate to have the worst enemy
in the whole history of the world right
the trash value guys right but but
you're selling a crusade there's nothing
that energizes people and keep that
momentum going like a like a crusade
right you're out there trying to save
the world you're trying to make a
difference with your life right and then
the third thing is you have competition
competition inside the company I was a
master at promoting competition inside
the company right like Lawrence Walker I
get him taking on a dick Walker you know
down in Tampa Florida you know I mean I
was I had I had a gift of always egging
people alone along a little bit okay so
if you want to if you want to keep
momentum once you get it there are three
keys you grow by multiplication you keep
recruiting this folks for 20 years
it's preseve a Williams the first thing
I look for every day on my desk
Cathy hearing my secretary the first
thing I did when I went in the office
before I talked to boo or anybody and
gotten and got in my million things I
needed to do okay the first thing I did
every morning was look at recruiting
numbers first thing I did every morning
the second thing I did was signed 200
gogo letters that's the first thing I
did and got that out of the way first
thing every morning right and so you've
got to have a women talk to you about
that in the morning to monitoring this
kind of stuff so you
you know you can tissa pate when you are
slowing down right when you're you're
fixing hit a brick wall down the road
correct so if you if you're growing my
multiplication if you've got people out
there recruiting best friends you're
picking up policies of best friends you
know making presentations to best
friends building friends were there
recruits praising recognizing people
promoting district managers promoting
division manager promoting our VPS and
you've got people you're teaching people
how to do all these same kind of things
to build these powerful relationships
right then you're guaranteed that you're
going to keep that momentum going if you
have an enemy you've got to have an
enemy you've got to have something you
get people riled up about and then the
third thing is you create competition
inside your own organization or inside
the company right
[Music]
the most important word ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
so it would be like a little beacon pay
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details